hey guys how's it going my name is Mark
Meyer but then again you probably
already knew that parade my doors open
BRB I'm back now
but you could probably already see that
because you see things real good great
anyway welcome back to markiplier
Monday's hooray it's back to the normal
schedule I know that I kind of fell out
of doing regular vlogs because there
were so many other things going on in my
life not just like with the surgery that
happened a month ago but with like all
the conventions I was going to and all
the things that I was doing in surprise
trips to like New York and whatnot which
are all great great but not good enough
to excuse me from not doing these on a
regular basis because I want to make
sure that you guys know that this
connection here is like the most
important thing in my life and it may
not seem like it to you but I'm working
my butt off in the background trying to
make sure you guys stay connected to me
because I respond to like comments here
and there and I respond to tweets here
and there and I respond to emails when I
can but I have so many of them that I
can't always give people the personal
attention that you know I'd like them to
give so know that in this video I'm
gonna be reading every single comment
and for like the next two hours after
there's boasted I'm gonna be responding
to comments as much as I can trying to
answer you guys questions also as asked
me anything you want to ask just in case
you know I might bring it up in the next
vlog coming up next week because these
are gonna be coming out every Monday but
either way that's besides the point
actually that's the entire point so I
guess I really can't flop it off great
first off I haven't been telling you
guys about the other series that I've
been doing with other people I mean I
mentioned this on Facebook and Twitter
and thank you everyone that follows me
on Facebook and Twitter and wants to
hear about my boring ideas on life but I
finally did a series with the game
grumps and the game grumps I've been
yammering on about for ages now and Ross
grump and I we played Super Mario Kart
together and it's a lot of fun the
series is almost completely out right
now
it was just on part 5 yesterday so part
6 is coming out today and there's one
more part after that so you can check it
out through right here me and Ross are
playing and raging and talking a Super
Mario Kart which is one of my favorite
games from old times I used to play with
my brother all the time way back when
and raised in raged in rages about how
hard it was on
hundred and fifty CC mode you guys know
what I'm talking about those that play
Super Mario Kart either in the past or
right now the second thing that I
haven't told you about is I did another
sketch with sin ago this was like a
month ago but I never mentioned it on a
vlog or anything it is called ed Edgar's
adoption Emporium and you can check it
out right here it's totally silly but
totally hilarious and the guys really
worked hard on this one so check it out
see if you have a laugh let me know what
you think and there's a secret special
message at the end they're great thirdly
I've got a bunch of friends coming into
town over the next two weeks of Tyler
who some people remember from the Uno's
livestream Wade is coming down to LA and
then also Bob so at some point all three
of them will be over here in LA which is
amazing because they have not been out
here in almost a year
like it's been a long long time but what
with people's lives and Bob going to law
school
I mean frivolous things like that where
I'm sitting at home in my underwear
playing video games great so that's
gonna be a lot of fun we're gonna be
doing a lot of collabs together we're
gonna be playing a lot of games and then
at some point we'll nail down the date
for that charity livestream that we're
gonna be doing together tonight so we're
gonna win
yes we're doing a charity livestream
together all together all of us together
in one place one thing we're doing
together this great so we don't know an
exact date for that yet it's gonna be
sometime in the next two weeks so stay
tuned for listening on Facebook and
Twitter and obviously here in the next
vlog next Monday I'm gonna tell you
about it next week next time next time
lastly I just wanted to take a minute to
say how grateful I am for your support
over the years
I mean this channel specifically has
been around since May 26 of 2012 and
people are coming up and saying like oh
you're coming up on three years
congratulations barking Moo and I'm like
awed I've kind of been here three years
already
because of my last channel but thank you
nonetheless and it's been more
interesting because with the recent fan
game that I played dream DXE the draw my
life that I did about two years back
just came up actually I think almost
exactly two years back on May 4th I
believe and it was interesting to see
because that is like a piece of my life
it's a story that I tell about the
hardships and the good times that I've
had throughout my life the kind
led to me being here it's the Cliff
Notes version of my life
and and what is amazing to me is that
that resonates with so many people I
mean over eight million people have seen
it and the fact that 8 million people
are interested in my life it throws me
for a loop and I'm kind of fascinated
that you guys find me good old boring
mark EMU enough to watch my life on
Flippa heck yeah my hair kind of looks
like a bird down great what I'm trying
to say is that video resonated with a
lot of people and on a meta level that
means that my life or the story of my
life resonates with a lot of people and
that's very meaningful to me and it puts
me in this odd position because people
come up to me and I was just at the
Renaissance Festival with the game
grumps if you want to see some pictures
about that check out these scrolling
across the screen here don't I look
dashing and handsome alongside Danny sex
bang but it's interesting to me because
people come up to me and they'll say how
they can relate to pieces of my life and
they can relate to how ice I went
through hardships and I came out a
better person for it and it puts me in a
weird position because you guys know
about my story but I have almost no way
to know about your story and I say yours
as a whole I know there are about a
million people watching this video and
there's a million stories to be told and
the fact that some of those stories go
untold is a little bit of a tragedy and
I wish shows a better way for it but the
only thing that I can do is encourage
you to keep telling your story you know
as a youtuber I have a platform through
which I can talk to you guys and I can
tell you whatever I want and the thing
about youtubers is sometimes they use
that for good I'm not calling anyone out
for that sometimes they use it for their
own personal gain and I'm not calling
anyone out for that either all I'm
saying is that YouTube is a platform
it's a really big soapbox where we can
stand up and we can speak to a crowd but
like we have to use that responsibly and
we have to try to do our best to make
sure that the message we're spreading is
worth spreading at all so if there was
ever a message that I wanted to spread
to you guys it's that you have more
power than you know
and your story deserves to be heard
just because my story can reach millions
of people does not make it more
meaningful impactful or important than
your story and this is me standing on my
soapbox telling you guys that you are
important and you matter and people may
be sick of hearing that but god damn and
I'm gonna tell it until the end of my
days because one of the greatest things
about this community that we've been
building for the past three years is
that you guys can talk to each other and
you guys can reach out to each other and
I've seen it over and over again and it
makes me more proud every time I do see
it in like Twitter Tumblr Facebook all
these disparate places that are kind of
away from the central hub of YouTube you
guys still have this sense of community
about you and other youtubers will still
say to the say like on my comment
section this is a vitriolic and whatever
but I have yet to see that and I'm in
the comments section right now for the
next two hours I'm hello hello me I'm
commenting down there but like it's
amazing because you guys can talk to
each other and you guys can reach out to
each other and you guys can spread love
you know everywhere you go and you guys
can spread inspiration everywhere you go
because that's the thing people need the
most sometimes is just knowing that
there's people that give a [ __ ] and
that's so hard to find some places and
it's so weird to say like that doesn't
happen people don't give a crap about
what's going on out there but you guys
do and even if you don't feel like you
do right now hey welcome to the
community you're gonna no matter what in
these next few weeks when I'm doing
these vlogs you're gonna feel like you
actually do give a crap and I hope you
do like it may sound crude at first but
giving a crap is like the most basic
part of being this community and the
charity efforts that we do it in
reaching out to people and helping
people and making the world a little bit
better all starts with giving a [ __ ] so
anyway that's enough blathering for
today I'm gonna be doing these vlogs
every week so if you have a question
that you want me to answer in the next
one please write in the comments below
I'll try to answer as many questions as
I can while I'm down there good luck to
you mark there's thousands of comments
but I'll be reading them as best I can I
been able to get through all of them
before but it all depends on how many
there are so challenging comments you
can write and I'll see how many I can
actually get through so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
those other videos that I talked about
in the beginning of the video they're
linked down in the description too and
check out the other cool stuff that I've
done that I've forgotten that I will
also link down there thank you everybody
so much for watching thank you guys for
being such an amazing community thank
you guys so much for the support over
the three years that I've been doing
YouTube I check out my draw my life even
if you want if you haven't seen it
already and thanks again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye